la república checa- primero ese fue el
lema bajo el que miles de personas se
manifestaron contra su gobierno en praga
la capital checa acusan a la coalición
dirigida por el primer ministro de
centroderecha petrov ya la de prestar
más ayuda y atención a la ucrania
devastada por la guerra que a sus
propios ciudadanos
estamos aquí como personas que tienen la
misma dirección el mismo objetivo
estamos aquí con personas que quieren
salvar esta república estamos aquí como
patriotas
los manifestantes también culpan al
gobierno de dañar la economía del país
con sus sanciones contra rusia debemos
poner fin a las sanciones que no
perjudican a rusia sino a nuestra gente
a nuestros empresarios y a nuestro país
y lo más importante acabar con esta
guerra en la que nuestro gobierno
insiste en que estamos metidos pero no
lo estamos esta guerra no es nuestra
pero la protesta fue principalmente por
el aumento de la inflación impulsada por
la subida de los precios de la energía
debido a la caída del suministro de gas
desde
la república checa que ocupa actualmente
la presidencia de turno de la unión
europea ha acogido a unos 400.000
refugiados de ucrania y ha prestado una
importante ayuda militar y humanitaria
al país el viernes el gobierno de fial
ha sobrevivió a una moción de censura en
el parlament o iniciada por dos partidos
de la oposición el primer ministro
declaró que la manifestación fue
organizada por personas pro rusas contra
los intereses de la república checa-